supongamos que tenemos la función fx
igual a equis cuadrada más uno y que
queremos calcular el valor promedio de
esta función f en el intervalo en
el intervalo cerrado 03 en el intervalo
que va de 0 a 3 y te invito a que le
pongas pausa al vídeo e intentes hacerlo
por tu cuenta
sobre todo si has visto vídeos previos
donde se calcula el valor promedio de
funciones
deberás poder calcular el valor promedio
de esta función sobre este intervalo
bien supongo que ya lo intentaste vamos
entonces a visualizar qué es lo que está
ocurriendo antes de calcular cuál es
dicho valor promedio
aquí tenemos entonces nuestro eje y este
de aquí es nuestro eje x vamos a
graficar la función en el intervalo
cerrado 03 aquí tenemos el 0 1 2 3 y la
escala para la aie veamos cuando x es
igual a 0
fx es igual a 1 aquí tenemos
efe de 0 igual a 1 cuando x es igual a 2
efe de 2 es igual a 5 pero aquí espera
la escala no es la adecuada vamos a
corregir la el valor de la función llega
hasta 10 aquí tenemos el 10
este es el 5 y luego aquí tendríamos
veamos 1 2 3 4 no no está bien eso
hagámoslo bien 52 luego otra vez entre 2
no está mal ya se ve mejor entonces aquí
tendríamos el 5 y ahora sí efe de 0 es
igual a 1 efe de uno es igual a 2
obviamente son distintas las escalas de
iu y x
tenemos aquí f de 5 y f de 3 que es 3 al
cuadrado 91 10 f de 3 igual a 10 y esto
se va a ver más o menos así esta es la
gráfica de la función
esta es la gráfica de igual a fx y nos
interesa el valor promedio de la función
en el intervalo cerrado que va de 0 a 3
podríamos ya aplicar la fórmula pero es
importante que sepas qué es lo que de
hecho significa esta fórmula de tal
manera que no es necesario memorizar la
fórmula si sabes lo que representa
entonces el promedio de la función f es
igual
la integral definida sobre este
intervalo básicamente el área bajo esta
curva esto es igual a la integral
definida de 0 a 3 de la función efe que
es equis cuadrada más 1 de x así es que
vamos a tomar esta área y la vamos a
dividir entre la longitud del intervalo
para obtener la altura promedio de esta
región que es el valor promedio de la
función así es que la vamos a dividir
entre b menos a que es 3 - 0 o
simplemente 3 y ahora sólo tenemos que
evaluar esto así es que esto es igual a
un tercio de la anti derivada de x
cuadrada que es x cúbica sobre tres más
la anti derivada de uno que es x y esto
evaluado de 0 a 3 lo cual es igual a un
tercio que multiplica a vamos a evaluar
la anti derivada en 3 voy a usar otro
color aquí tenemos 3 al cubo 27 entre 3
9 93 - ahora evaluamos en el límite
inferior evaluamos en 0 lo cual es 0 al
cubo entre 30 simplemente 0 - 0 y así
entonces esto nos queda déjame cerrar
los corchetes con el mismo color esto es
igual a un tercio por 12 o 12 sobre 3 lo
cual es igual a 4 esto es igual a 4 lo
cual es el valor promedio de nuestra
función el valor promedio en nuestra
función sobre este intervalo el valor
promedio de nuestra función sobre este
intervalo es igual a 4 y observa que
nuestra función de hecho toma ese valor
en algún punto del intervalo en algún
punto del intervalo un punto que es
menor a 2 y mayor que 1 ya me molesté
tiene ese valor de c
parece que la función vale 4 y esto es
algo que siempre se va a dar este es de
hecho el teorema de valor medio para
integrar
y ya lo revisaremos con mayor detalle en
otro vídeo pero aquí podemos ver
gráficamente que si tomamos un
rectángulo cuya altura sea el valor
promedio de la función y cuya base sea
la longitud del intervalo dicho
rectángulo va a tener un área que en
este caso es igual a 12 y que es esta
que estoy dibujando aquí esa área es
exactamente igual al área bajo la curva
de la función esto es el valor promedio
de la función por la longitud del
intervalo en fin espero que este vídeo
te haya sido útil